[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend
sportliche Erfolgsgeschichten später
wieder mit dir Katja genau schön guten
Abend dann sind hier unsere Themen an
diesem
Mittwoch Halbzeit beim Klimagipfel viele
Länder tun sich schwer mit dem Ausstieg
aus Öl Kohle und Gas das Ringen um
effektive Maßnahmen geht weiter
Putin wieder auf großer Bühne der
russische Präsident besucht die
golfregionen um seinen Einfluss dort zu
festigen sonnige Aussichten für
Reiseunternehmen nach Corona sorgt
aufgestautes fernwet trotz gestiegener
Preise wieder für gute
Umsätze 200 Wissenschaftler warnen zur
Halbzeit der Weltklimakonferenz vor
unumkehrbaren Folgen für unseren
Planeten wenn die die globale Erwärmung
auf 1,5° ansteigt könne dies etwa zum
Absterben von Regenwäldern oder
Abschmelzen der Westantarktis führen ob
diese Nachricht die Entscheider in Dubai
beeinflusst sich auf ein globales
Abkommen zum schrittweisen Ausstieg von
Kohle Öl und Gas zu einigen fraglich
mehr von Andreas
Stamm viel Glanz und Größe straf
durchorganisiert aber in der Substanz da
hakt es noch der koppräsident als
Ölmanager heftig Kri sucht nach
Kompromissen beim wichtigsten Thema kann
die Konferenz den Abschied von Öl Gas
Kohle beschließen die Zeit drängt denn
2023 werde das global heißeste je
gemessene Jahr laut dem EU
klimawandeldienst liegt die
Durchschnittstemperatur bislang um 1,46°
höher als vor der Industrialisierung
noch ein Ausnahmejahr aber ein weiterer
wegruf für die
Weltklimakonferenz wenn man sich die
tatsächlichen Pläne der Regierungen
anschaut stellt man fest dass bis zum
Jahr 2030 die Kohleproduktion steigen
soll und dann erst langsam abflacht bis
zum Jahr 2050 soll die Öl und
Gasproduktion steigen und dann
vielleicht ein Plateau erreichen das ist
mit einem 1,5° Pfad in keiner Weise
vereinbar den Kurswechsel wollen die
Hälfte der rund 200 Staaten vollziehen
der erfahrenste Verhandler der
Bundesregierung erklärt es dürfte zäh
werden das ist eine brachiale
Veränderung der Weltarchitektur
und deshalb
tun sich viele Länder auch so schwer und
wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind mit uns wir
haben uns ja auch nicht ganz leicht
getan den Kohleausstieg in unserem Land
auf den Weg zu bringen für mich ist das
hier international das letzte große
Aufflackern der fossilen Welt kann das
schon in Dubai gelöscht werden die
Weltklimakonferenz wird darüber noch
eine knappe Woche lang streiten die
geprägt sein wird von einem Tage und
nächteelangen
Verhandlungsmarathon ja gehen wir live
nach Dubai dort ist Andreas Stamm für
uns was lässt sich zur Halbzeit der
Weltklimakonferenz
sagen ja das es eine gemischte Bilanz
ist es begann ja mit diesem Paukenschlag
erstmals wurde eine gewichtige
Entscheidung am ersten Tag einer solchen
Konferenz getroffen ein Fond für
Klimaschäden aufgesetzt da sollen reiche
Industrieländer reinzahlen das sollte
beflügeln das sollte dem ganzen hier
einen Spirit geben mittlerweile ist das
schon ein bisschen ja ich sag mal ja
wieder Realität eingekehrt denn die
Großzügigkeit der reichen Länder lässt
auf sich warten und eben auch beim
anderen großen them dem großen Thema da
haakt es eben und daran wird sich diese
Konferenz messen lassen das ist gar
keine Frage wie weit kommt man eben
dabei
Treibhausgasemissionen schnell und
drastisch zu senken das wollen ja alle
also eben der Ausstieg aus dem fossilen
Zeitalter und viele viele Delegierte die
es hier gibt die fassen das so zusammen
die Welt blickt und geht in die richtige
Richtung aber eben in trippelstritten wo
doch eigentlich ein wirklich großer Wurf
nötig wäre danke für die Einschätzung
nach Dubai Andreas Stamm ja und mehr zur
Weltklimakonferenz und unter anderem
einen interaktiven Globus gibt's in
unserer ZF heute App und darauf können
Sie z.B sehen was passiert wenn das
Polareis weiter schmilzt und welche
Folgen der Klimawandel für Menschen und
Tiere
hat die Uhr um den Haushalt 2024 noch
dieses Jahr zu beschließen läuft langsam
ab in den nikolausstiefeln der
ampelregierung waren heute auch keine
unverhofften Juwelen mit den man die
Milliardenlöcher stopfen könnte am
Vortag kam am Vormittag kam das Kabinett
zusammen und es gab wieder keine
Einigung das Kernproblem grüne SPD und
FDP haben offenbar weiter
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen wo die
fehlenden Milliarden für den Haushalt
herkommen sollen Diana Zimmermann in
Berlin vor dem Kanzleramt wo zur Stunde
ja weiter verhandelt wird was kannst du
zum Stand der Dinge
sagen ja es gibt gewisse Anzeichen dafür
dass eine Einigung vielleicht doch nicht
mehr allzu lange auf sich warten lässt
erstens sitzen tatsächlich der Kanzler
der Wirtschafts und der Finanzminister
jetzt wieder hier hinter mir im
Kanzleramt zusammen um eine Lösung zu
finden zweitens haben sie sich jeweils
heute überhaupt nicht gemeldet das ist
nach Wochen in denen sie sich
gegenseitig immer vorgeschlagen haben wo
der andere von seinen lieblingsvorhaben
abrücken könnte eine Neuigkeit und
deutet darauf hin dass es wirklich
ernsthafte Verhandlungen gibt der Druck
ist enorm wenn es keinen regulären
Haushalt 24 gibt dann müssen viele
Bürger und Unternehmen noch länger
darauf warten zu wissen ob es im
nächsten Jahr Kredite und Fördergelder
für sie gibt das erhöht natürlich die
Unsicherheit der Kanzler hat einen
zusätzlichen Anreiz diesen Haushalt
möglichst bald zu stopfen denn er hat
einen SPD Parteitag am Wochenende und da
möchte er zur Halbzeit der Ampel
sicherlich nicht als ein Kanzler ohne
Haushalt dastehen sondern als ein Löser
von Problemen wir sind gespannt vielen
Dank dien nach
Berlin jetzt nach Nahost im gaz Streifen
besonders im Süden wird weiter erbittert
gekämpft gestern die wohl heftigsten
Angriffe durch Israel heute beerdigten
die Betroffenen Palästinenser die Opfer
nach augenzeugen berichten leben
inzwischen 10ta000ende in Zelten auf der
Straße es Fehler an Nahrungsmitteln
Wasser und Unterkünften die israelischen
Truppen veröffentlichten heute Videos
die ein riesiges hamaswaffenlager zeigen
sollen mit hunderten Panzerfäusten
Panzerabwehrraketen Granaten und Drohnen
das Depot soll sich nah ein Schule im
Norden des gazerastreifens befinden ja
die größte Gefahr für einen Flächenbrand
in der Region sehen Experten gerade im
Westjordanland bei Übergriffen jüdischer
Siedler auf die lokale palästinensische
Bevölkerung hat es seit Oktober mehrere
Tote gegeben im Westjordanland leben
rund 3 Millionen Palästinenser aber auch
600.000 Israelis in 20000 Siedlungen die
Palästinenser beanspruchen die Gebiete
als Teil eines eigenen Staates auch aus
karabat Bani Hassan berichtet luten
leinos sie besichtigen die Spuren eines
Überfalls der einen ihrer Nachbarn das
Leben kostete und bei dem drei weitere
Durchschüsse schwer verletzt wurden
Jamal hat den Angriff mit Glück überlebt
er schildert wie sie von etwa 20
bewaffneten Siedlern bedroht
wurden erst zündeten sie ein Auto dort
drüben an und dann diesen Wagen hier von
meinem Cousin anschließend begannen sie
auf mich zu schießen wir waren alle in
großer
Gefahr auch der Bürgermeister war dabei
als es passierte er zeigt uns
handyfnahmen darauf ist zu sehen wie
Jugendliche der militanten
Siedlerbewegung top Hills youth mit
Gewehren auf sie zielen Autos in den
Abgrund stürzen und unter den Augen
israelischer Soldaten
anzünden es wird brutaler sie schießen
gezielt mit der Absicht zu töten alle
Siedler sind jetzt bewaffnet und die
Armee beschützt sie auch um die Gebiete
für sie zu
sichern wir besuchen den Anführer der
radikalen siedlerjugend um zu erfahren
warum er das tut doch er will nicht mit
uns reden solche Überfälle im
Westjordanland haben seit dem
hamasüberfall stark zugenommen sagen
Menschenrechtler seit dem 7 oktober gibt
es fast jede Nacht Angriffe und zwar
überall dort im Westjordanland wo es
Ländereien gibt die Siedler von den
Palästinensern übernehmen
wollen
auch Jamal fürchtet dass der Albtraum
weitergeht er glaubt dass die Siedler
wiederkommen um sich sein Land zu
holen seitdem russlandspräsident Putin
den Krieg gegen die Ukraine begonnen hat
ist der international weitgehend
isoliert Russland verlässt er nur noch
selten heute aber reist er zum
wichtigsten Handelspartner in der
arabischen Welt in die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate und wurde dort pompös
empfangen Putin Flug danach noch weiter
nach Saudi-Arabien trotz internationalem
Haftbefehl droht ihm keine Festnahme da
beide Länder den Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof nicht anerkennen wir
wollen jetzt nach Moskau gehen zu Armin
Körper Armin was will Putin mit dieser
Reise
bezwecken Putin sendet mit dieser Reise
gleich mehrere Signale politisch will er
sich ins Spiel bringen beim suchen nach
einer Friedenslösung im Nahostkrieg vor
allem geht es aber dem Kremmel um die
Bilder denn die sollen dre Monate vor
der russischen Präsidentschaftswahl und
fast 2 Jahre nach dem überfallau die
Ukraine zeigen dass der kremmelchef
begrüßt wird und zwar mit großer
Delegation und noch größerem Pomp trotz
der Sanktionen trotz der Versuche ihn zu
isolieren und auch trotz des
internationalen Haftbefehls dabei sind
das Reiseziel und der Zeitpunkt
keinesfalls zufällig während die UN
Klimakonferenz in Dubai tagt taucht
Putin in der direkten Nachbarschaft auf
und versucht so dem Westen die Show zu
stehlen danke Amin nach
Moskau sich gegen Putins Russland
verteidigen schon lange drängt die
Ukraine dabei auf mehr Geld und Waffen
jetzt hat der Chef des präsidentenbüros
in Kiev konkret vor einer Niederlage
gewarnt für den Fall dass ushilfen
ausblieben gegen die russischen Angriffe
schützt sich die Ukraine nicht nur
militärisch in der Stadt hakiv etwa
werden Schulen in den Untergrund verlegt
Tim Kröger berichtet dicke Mauern
hunderte Stahlverstrebungen und das so
tief in der Erde wie notwendig zum
Schutz der Kinder hier in der Region um
hakiv entstehen zwei der ersten
untergrundschulen denn die russische
Grenze ist nicht weit
entfernt es ist unmöglich Kinder aus den
Klassen zu evakuieren denn es dauert 30
bis 40 Sekunden bis die Bombe kommt
deswegen sollen sie unmittelbar im
Bunker unterrichtet werden
hunderte Kinder sollen in Zukunft
geschützt im Untergrund lernen und so
endlich nicht mehr auf onlineunterricht
angewiesen
sein durch die vergangenen zwei Jahre
die der Krieg läuft sind die Kinder sehr
müde vom
onlineunterricht sie brauchen
psychologische Unterstützung sie müssen
ihre Lehrer wieder persönlich sehen und
hören der ajährige ausakiv lernt seit Z
Jahren in einem Hinterzimmer der
Bäckerei in der seine Mutter arbeitet
und würde gerne endlich wieder richtig
in die Schule
gehen dort sind Freunde wir treffen uns
da sonst leben wir voneinander
entfernt schon jetzt haben Kinder in der
Stadt hakif selbst in U-Bahnstationen
Präsenzunterricht aber auch hier
entstehen Klassenräume im
Untergrund die Stadtverwaltung muss
alles tun damit Kinder in der Lage sind
zu lernen und das machen wir deshalb
wird unsere erste untergrundschule
gebaut und solche Schulen werden in
jedem wohntel der stadtkiv
gebaut mit untergrundschulen so die
Hoffnung kehren auch wieder Menschen
zurück in die Region die vor dem Krieg
geflüchtet
sind in der Nähe von Moskau ist ein
proussischer Politiker aus der Ukraine
ermordet worden der ukrainische
Geheimdienst hat sich zu der Tat bekannt
der
46jährige Kiva war Abgeordneter des
ukrainischen Parlaments bevor er zu
Beginn der russischen Invasion na
Russland überlief der ukrainische
Geheimdienst sprach von einer gerechten
Tötung ein ähnliches Schicksal werde
auch andere Verräter der Ukraine
ereilen ein Streik noch vor Weihnachten
damit hatte ja die GDL gedroht nachdem
deren Chef weselski die
Tarifverhandlungen mit der Bahn schon
nach der zweiten Gesprächsrunde Ende
November für gescheitert erklärt hat und
seit einer Stunde ist klar ab morgen
Abend stehen die Züge für 24 Stunden
still erst für den Güter ab 22 Uhr dann
auch für den Personenverkehr teilte die
GDL mit
egal ob ein fernes Abenteuer oder die
Naherholung um die Ecke die Reiselust
der Deutschen ist groß und das trotz
Inflation davon hat in diesem Jahr
besonders der weltgrößte Reisekonzern
die TUI profitiert rund 19 Millionen
Reisende Buchten Ihren Urlaub dort der
Umsatz der stieg um 25% auch weil Reisen
generell teurer geworden ist
voraussichtlich wird's im kommenden Jahr
noch teurer aber die Tourismusbranche
die zeigt sich krisensicher Clemens
Altmann mit den
Einzelheiten trotz Inflation
Klimakatastrophen und weltweiter
Unsicherheit die deutschen sehnen sich
nach Urlaub nach Corona stiegen die
Buchungen bei den Reiseunternehmen
durchschnittlich um
15%. wer sich leisten kann wird
sicherlich auch in Zukunft verreisen
viele Deutsche sitzen jetzt schon
aufgepacken Koffern natürlich ist eine
gewisse Unsicherheit da was das
Finanzielle angeht aber Urlaub bleibt
die populärste Form des Glücks und wir
Deutschen wollen gerne auch nächstes
Jahr wieder unterwegs sein Angebot und
Nachfrage Regeln den Preis einerseits
höhere personalerzeuger und
Energiepreise sowie gestiegene Flug und
Versicherungskosten bei den Anbietern
andererseits nach den pandemiejahren
eine extrem hohe Nachfrage nach
Urlaubsreisen und eine relativ hohe
Zahlungsbereitschaft wir haten ja dieses
Jahr auch schon den Trend dass ist so 30
bis 40% hochging also das wird so sage
ich mal ähnlich bleiben wobei es noch
ein her sag ich mal so 5 bis 10%
noch mal hochgehen wird je nach
Geldbeutel fallen die Urlaubsziele
unterschiedlich aus ich mache eine
Kreuzfahrt von savonna
über Ibizza nach Tanger und dann in
Westeuropa hoch bis Bremerhafen vor
dieser ganze inflationsgeschichte ne war
das alles ein bisschen günstiger jetzt
warum auch immer wird immer nur teurer
ne Geld was ich als junger Mensch
verdiene im Job davon kann ich mir kein
Urlaub leisten auch deshalb bleibt mehr
als ein Drittel der Deutschen in der
Heimat fährt vor allem nach Bayern oder
Mecklenburg Vorpommern oder bleibt
einfach zu
Hause da ist es auch schön so jetzt der
Sport mit Katja und den Achtelfinals im
dfbpokal ja gestern vier Partien heute
auch wieder eine davon lautet VfB gegen
BVB erst vor dreieinhalb Wochen gab es
diese Ansetzung in der Fußball
buundesliga damals hat Stuttgart mit 2
Z1 gewonnen und Katrin Müller Hohenstein
in Stuttgart dieser Sieg war völlig
verdient absolut Katja der VfB spielt
insgesamt eine mitreißende Saison auch
dank der beiden superknipser girassi und
undf die beiden haben schon 24 Tore
erzielt mal zum Vergleich die drei
Toptorjäger des BVB kommen gemeinsam nur
auf die Hälfte und der BVB in dieser
Saison auch irgendwie mit zwei
Gesichtern in der Liga stand die
Mannschaft noch nie unter den Top 3 aber
in der Champions League da haben Sie
zuletzt groß aus aufgetrumpft haben
frühzeitig die K Phase erreicht in einer
ziemlichen Hammergruppe wenn die
Mannschaft heute Abend dieses Gesicht
zeigt dann wird das ein absolutes
Klassespiel und wir freuen uns drauf ab
20:15 Uhr sind wir drauf hier in
Stuttgart ja ZDF überträgt also live
danke Katrin werfen wir jetzt noch mal
einen Blick auf die pokalergebnisse von
gestern wer steht im Viertelfinale
regionallig ist FC Homburg verliert
gegen St Pauli 1:4 Kaiserslautern
schlägt Nürnberg 2:0 Magdeburg
unterliegt in der Nachspielzeit Fortuna
Düsseldorf mit 1 Z2 und Borussia
mönchenggladbach gewinnt 1:0 gegen den
VfL Wolfsburg und das war ein Zittersieg
für die Gladbacher 9 Minuten lang wenig
Chancen auf beiden Seiten Tore gleich
gar nicht also ging es in die
Verlängerung und da jubelte Gladbach
nach dem Treffer von Joker Manu con in
der
120 Minute Schock bei den Wolfsburgern
da hält die auswärtskrise
an Deutschlands
fußballnationalspielerinnen dürfen
weiter vom Olympia Ticket träumen sie
machten gestern den Gruppensieg in der
nations League klar wobei da sehr viel
Glück mit im Spiel war GEG Gegner Wales
in rot war in swansy im letzten
Gruppenspiel über weite Strecken das
bessere Team die dfb1 nur in der zweiten
Hälfte mit einer Torchance durch Elisa
sens dann parallel spielt Dänemark
überraschend gegen Island verlor ist
Deutschland in der Finalrunde Ende
Februar mit Horst Rubisch vielleicht
macht er auch noch länger weiter danke
schön Katja so zum Schluss noch dass das
Time Magazine hat Superstar Taylor Swift
zur Persönlichkeit des Jahres 2023
gekürt Begründung niemand anderes auf
diesem Planeten könne heutzutage so
viele Menschen so gut bewegen als
geschäftsbau ein Imperium aufgebaut und
als Popikone hitparadenrekorde geb
ja sehr pompös fehlt jetzt noch das
Mittwochslotto hier sind die
Gewinnzahlen 2 15 27 42 43 45 Superzahl
1 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zf.de und auf der ZF Textseite
557 morgen oft trüb oder neblig Sonne
ist aber auch drin mehr Wetter gleich
mit horneer das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka gegen 21:30 Uhr von uns
war's das danke Ihnen noch einen
entspannten
[Musik]
Abend guten Abend morgen überquert uns
ein kleines Zwischenhoch namens
Evangelia und in der Nacht zu Freitag
und Freitag Vormittag bringtief Regen
und wenn der auf gefrorenen Boden fällt
der Regen dann wird es spiegelglatt
heute Nacht erwarten wir die Glätte vor
allen Dingen im Nordosten durch Schnee
und Schneeregen im Westen ist es zum
Teil klar dann bildet sich Nebel die
Temperaturen sinken auf +2 bis -7° und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 0 und 6°. am Vormittag kann es
am ehesten in Sachsen und an der OST
noch für einige schneeregenschauer
reichen sonst wird das ein trüber Tag
wenn sich der Nebel auflöst dann scheint
die Sonne aber auch mal strahlend und
dann kommt von Westen der neue Regen
heran in der Nacht zu Freitag und
Freitag vormittag dann wird es in der
Westhälfte sehr gefährlich glatt dieser
Glatteisregen erreicht dann am Samstag
auch den Osten und über das zweite
Adventswochenende wird es deutlich
milder das möchte ich Ihnen noch etwas
genauer zeigen am Freitag liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei -3 bis + 7° im
Laufe des zweiten Advents flutet die
milde Luft ganz Deutschland am Montag
haben wir dann 5 bis 13° dann geht es
auch den Schnee Flächen an den Kragen am
Montag liegen allenfalls im Erzgebirge
im Bayerischen Wald und am Alpenrand
noch 20 bis 40 cm guten Abend